with almost 500 sessions in next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
beyond court beyond Google then stay
tuned because here's the rewind if
you're large-scale company with lots of
employees devices and applications then
chances are your IT department talks a
lot about security and it's
understandable given our technology age
there's lots of attack vectors to your
company's data this is why about ten
years ago Google decided we wanted to
get rid of VPNs deciding that no network
was actually safe and the only way to
improve security was to evaluate each
request as it happened and this was the
beginning of beyond Corp at its core
beyond Corp is comprised of three things
that the enterprise can control first
policies to let you define what and who
should or shouldn't have access second
the set of attributes about the specific
request giving you important context and
third applications and data than need
protecting with this in place beyond
Corp lets us ask various security
questions per request at various stages
for example is this employee a real user
is the device they are using known or
has it been compromised is the network
path vulnerable and finally given all
that data should the user be allowed to
access the applications this is done
through a set of four main tools first
the identity tools which let you do
things like keep a database of users
their job roles in their access levels
along with the ability to have secondary
credentials and short-lived sessions
next endpoint verification which boils
down to having a database of your
devices understanding what operating
systems are supported and what device
information can be used to make access
decisions then there's the identity
aware proxy which allows admins to
configure which people have access to
which applications and finally the
control engine which contains a list of
these items matched up with buckets of
access that allow for easy scale to
thousands of applications in your
environment but let's look at something
a little more specific let's say an
employee is sitting inside Google's
headquarters at the Identity level we
know it's Sophia and then lock in
we know the MacBook because we have its
device ID and then it's running the
right operating system that we trust we
also know they're coming from the right
IP and then it's a corporate device so
we know they can access the data they
need and the proxy applies that policy
this person on this device has access to
the bug systems and the admin tools
what's interesting is how this changes
when Sophia moves to the coffee shop we
still know it's Sophia but they're using
their own tablet which we don't know
anything about and don't trust the
operating system our rules engine then
notes that in the current state Sophia
can't access the bug system but in that
current state so if you can access some
systems like calendar and email giving
us the right level of access to the
person and security to the corporate
data if you'd like to see the full talk
check out the link in the description
below and don't forget to subscribe to
the cloud YouTube channel for more great
next rewind content thanks for watching
you
[Music]